el caos en Twitter parece no tener fin
44 mil millones de dólares después hay
lo más que le esperaba una oleada de
problemas con un plan en concreto Cuando
entró a las oficinas el 28 de octubre
reducir hasta la mitad su plantilla de
7.500 trabajadores
tengan en cuenta que Twitter hará muchas
tonterías en los próximos meses
mantendremos lo que funcione y
cambiaremos lo que no no obstante muchos
opinan que los experimentos de más han
ido muy lejos mientras prohibía el
teletrabajo y exigía jornadas laborales
de mínimo 40 horas semanales organizaba
fiestas con sus empleados mientras
planeaba el despido de muchos que tenían
que recurrir a los medios para enterarse
de Su futuro y del de la empresa sus
políticas laxas respecto a La regulación
de contenido y la pérdida de contratos
publicitarios multimillonarios han
puesto a Twitter contra las cuerdas uno
de los momentos más críticos en la
empresa fue este jueves tras la renuncia
masiva de sus trabajadores tras semanas
de correos con ultimátums el escritorio
de mas empezó a llenarse de cartas de
dimisión
decidir unirme a Twitter hace siete años
y medio fue una de las decisiones más
fáciles de mi vida Decidí irme hoy Fue
totalmente lo opuesto
casi dos años en la tienda de Twitter y
hoy es mi último día una oleada de
emociones pero sobre todo gratitud con
una respuesta dura por parte de la
dirección cierre de sus edificios y
bloqueo al acceso de los trabajadores
provocando una avalancha de apagones en
la red social de la que muchos
personajes públicos ya han empezado
hasta a despedirse
si Twitter está a punto de implosionar
Solo quiero decir que ha sido un viaje
increíble con hasta una nueva red social
sonando como posible reemplazo mastodon
más parece no tener miedo y ha sostenido
que los usuarios siguen creciendo Y que
la plataforma solo mejorará